hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
another two weeks have passed since we
met up to look at all the map changes
and subtle updates in fortnight chapter
2 so let's jump back in again
Christmas 2019 is in the record books
and things are settling down once again
like usual plant your backside down and
relax for a few minutes
slap code a tomorrow in the fall tonight
shop to support this series and let's
see what fortnight in 2020 looks like
the biggest update is actually not a map
change it's a change to the season 3
emote best mates it's now a traversal
emote in homage I'll be using this old
video let me know if it gets annoying
[Music]
the map has received a hard reset over
the last seven days the snow has melted
away and those adorable ice locations
are no more to my surprise the shiverin
didn't survive the thaw even though it's
the closest of the winter build to be in
the naturally snowy biome the rest of
the map has been reverted back before
the pre Christmas celebrations the store
in retail Row is now a shell again it
got me thinking what will appear here
next we've had Halloween we've had
Christmas maybe it's time for a
Valentine's Day stop or do you reckon
over in pleasant Park the thaw has
resulted in muddy areas on the football
pitch or soccer field whichever name
doesn't affect you this detail gives me
hope for other tiny minut subtle details
to spot in future weeks but yeah I
understand to most people this is
completely insignificant the logjam yard
is now reset and I'm good to say this
but all the misfit toys have vanished
completely
I wondered over to the crashed truck as
I hoped this would be a great sub story
plot that we could keep an eye on but
nothing is there at all no crash site no
truck no pie bridge bear things maybe
I'm a fool and haven't found the gang
yet maybe they're hiding somewhere out
in the world if you spot them please let
me know on Twitter
I'm Adam grenade over there and my DMS
are open over to softie Springs and the
Snowman FBI have vanished too but their
interactions with the world remain the
post they crashed into is still bent and
the resident evil nemesis sized holes in
the walls are here to stay - could we
see these repaired in future weeks or
will this house become rubble because
those were load-bearing walls things
could get interesting in salty springs
[Music]
and now on to the docks and the ice
factory has been demolished and the
original factory returns this is a real
shame but I guess this is a seasonal
thing now so it'll likely return next
year looking around the docks I couldn't
help but think there was something
missing here wasn't there something
around here last week did you guess it
yeah the flatbed truck with all the
biblical chairs upon it has finally left
the depot okay now we get to the real
map updates it hasn't traveled very far
but without a doubt this will be a key
update each week as we try to figure out
where the hell this beast is going let's
hear your thoughts and suggestions where
we'll be the new chair House of chapter
2 so I scanned over the map and try to
decide where I would put those chairs
and I think I found it above the dam is
the largest body of water on the game
and look at the central island it's
beautiful a new erection to monitor
together oh hang on I've got an idea
house watch now this erection is
official welcome to the world house now
at the first stage of restoration the
ruins are being rebuilt but if I know
fortnight this will likely become a
house akin to the architects house in
chapter 1 could this be the destination
for those chairs let's check back next
time
[Applause]
[Music]
so I think that's it for updates this
week I don't want to prolong this video
to ten minutes if it isn't needed but if
you spot anything please either hit me
up on Twitter I'll throw the link in the
description or join our discord and
contribute to the map update channel I'm
in there regularly as always a huge
thanks to those who continue to use my
code even with the lack of updates
recently you guys Wow P blow my mind I
really appreciate you I also want to
take this opportunity to thank one of
you guys in particular flash and wish
his little brother Kyle a speedy
recovery from an operation on his brain
stay strong brother I know you'll get
through this
thanks again everyone I'm Adam from
PlayStation granade it's been a pleasure
I'll see you next time
[Music]